our goal obviously at night after night
is to be funny and silly if you're in
the mood for that
late at night however sometimes events
are so horrifying and bleak that to come
out here and tell jokes just it's not
really possible and tonight sadly is one
of those nights at a time when we think
we've heard the worst stories about
senseless violence in our country then
it couldn't possibly get worse the news
out of Orlando yesterday is still
impossible to fathom that so many people
can lose their lives so quickly because
of one person's demented rage will never
make sense and God help us if it ever
does now I am NOT a pundit I am NOT an
expert and I've always always made it a
policy to stick to my job and keep my
opinions to myself
I have really tried very hard over the
years not to bore you with what I think
however I am a father of two I like to
believe I have a shred of common sense
and I simply do not understand why
anybody in this country is allowed to
purchase an own a semi-automatic assault
rifle it makes no sense
these these are weapons of war and they
have no place in civilian life I have
tried to understand this issue from
every side and it all comes down to this
nobody I know or have ever met in my
entire life should have access to a
weapon that can kill so many people so
quickly these mass shootings are
happening so often now that lamenting
them afterwards is becoming a national
ritual I do not know the answer but I
wanted to take just a moment here
tonight to agree with the rapidly
growing sentiment in America that it's
time to grow up and figure this out in
the meantime there are a lot of people
suffering in Orlando if you'd like to
help them visit go fund me.com slash
pulse Victims Fund now here's what we're
gonna do we're gonna take a break and
then go back to doing whatever it is we
do here I've never figured that out but
I thank you very much for listening and
we'll be right back you see that